MARK MEREDITH.
JUST THINK OF THIS.
MARK AND JACQUI WERE GETTING
INTO THIS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN FULLY
VACCINATED, HE HAD TWO BOOSTER
SHOTS.
HE WAS DOING EVERYTHING BY
PRECAUTION WEARING HIS MASK.
HE WAS WEARING HIS MASK PRIOR TO
THIS.
AN ISSUE I RAISED WITH DR. FAUCI
WHY THIS KEEPS HAPPENING, PEOPLE
THAT GET CASES, SOMETIMES REPEAT
CASES IN A WORLD WHERE WE'RE
TOLD WE'RE OVER THIS THING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> EVERYONE KNOWS SOMEONE WHO
HAS GOTTEN THIS AGAIN AND
SOMETIMES AGAIN AFTER THAT.
THEY'RE BEGINNING TO WONDER
ABOUT THE REGIMEN FOR TREATING
IT, WHETHER YOU GETS TWO
VACCINATION SHOTS, WHETHER YOU
GET A BOOSTER, ANOTHER BOOSTER.
THEY DON'T KNOW.
WHAT DO YOU TELL THEM?
>> NO DOUBT THAT THE VACCINES
THEMSELVES, PARTICULARLY VACCINE
PLUS THE BOOSTER AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WHEN YOU BECOME
ELIGIBLE FOR A BOOSTER, IF
YOU'RE OVER 50 YEARS OLD, YOU
GET ELIGIBILITY FOR TWO
BOOSTERS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS CLEAR
FROM THE DATA THAT EVEN THOUGH
VACCINES BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
DEGREE OF TRANSMISSIBILITY OF
THIS VIRUS DON'T PROTECT OVERLY
WELL AS IT WERE ABOUT INFECTION.
THEY PROTECT QUITE WELL AGAINST
SEVERE DISEASE, LEADING TO
HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATH.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO THE GIST OF WHAT DR. FAUCI
WAS SAYING, IT COULD BE WORST
MAYBE FOR THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
ADMIRAL BRETT GIROIR JOINS US.
HE WAS IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND ONE OF THE
KEY POINT MEN.
VERY GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
>> GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> Neil: LET ME ASK YOU WHAT
DR. FAUCI TOUCHED ON.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN FULLY
VACCINATED, SOME GETTING BOTH
BOOSTER SHOTS AND STILL COME
DOWN WITH THIS.
THE ARGUMENT BEING IT COULD HAVE
BEEN WORSE.
COULD IT HAVE BEEN WORSE?
>> WELL, YES, I AGREE WITH
DR. FAUCI.
TONY AND I ARE ON THE SAME PAGE
HERE.
WITH THE NEW VARIANTS, THE
VACCINES UNFORTUNATELY PROVIDE
VERY LITTLE PROTECTION AGAINST
GETTING INFECTED WITH COVID, BUT
THEY STILL DO PROVIDE
SUBSTANTIAL PROTECTION AGAINST
SEVERE DISEASE LIKE NEEDING TO
BE PUT IN THE HOSPITAL OR DEATH.
SO WHAT YOU SEE WITH THE
PRESIDENT JUST LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE, DESPITE HIS DOUBLE
BOOSTER, HE'S STILL GOT COVID
BECAUSE OF THE TRANSMISSIBILITY
OF THE VARIANT.
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT BECAUSE HE'S
VACCINATED AND CERTAINLY ON
PAXLOVID, HE CAN AVOID A SERIOUS
ILLNESS.
>> Neil: I HAD COVID.
I HAD IT TWICE.
THE SECOND TIME WAS DICEY.
I'M PART OF THE VULNERABLE PART
OF THE POPULATION WITH A
COMPROMISED IMMUNE SYSTEM.
I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO THAT I
WAS SURPRISED THAT I DID
EVERYTHING RIGHT, STILL CAME
DOWN WITH A PRETTY GOOD BOUT OF
THIS.
A LOT OF AMERICANS NO DOUBT ARE
SEEING THIS AND HEARING THIS AND
SAYING THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, THE MOST POWERFUL
MAN ON THE PLANET SURROUNDED BY
THE BEST MEDICAL PEOPLE GET IT
AND HELL NO, I'M NOT GETTING
VACCINATED.
I'M DONE WITH IT.
WHAT DO YOU TELL THEM?
>> I TELL THEM WHAT I TELL MY
FAMILY, VACCINES WILL PROVIDE
STRONG PROTECTION AGAINST
SERIOUS ILLNESS.
HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATH IF YOU
HAVE A NORMAL IMMUNE SYSTEM OR A
MODESTLY ABNORMAL IMMUNE SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT A GUARANTEE.
A VACCINE DOESN'T PUT A FORS
FIELD AROUND YOU.
MANY PEOPLE DON'T HAVE A PLAN TO
GET TREATED WITH PAXLOVID.
THEY NEED THAT.
IF YOU'RE ELDERLY, IF YOU HAVE
CHRONIC DISEASES, YOU REALLY DO
NEED THAT LAYER OF PROTECTION
LIKE THE PRESIDENT GOT.
AGAIN, NOTHING IS 100% IN
MEDICINE OR IN LIFE I GUESS
EXCEPT TAXES.
PAXLOVID ON TOP OF VACCINES
PROVIDE YOU THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY.
>> Neil: A LOT OF PEOPLE
CONFUSE, IF WE'RE GOING TO TREAT
THIS -- I KNOW DURING YOUR
ADMINISTRATION AND IN TO THIS
ONE, THERE'S BEEN AN ARGUMENT
THAT MAYBE WE START TREATING
THIS AS WE DO THE FLU.
YOU GET AN ANNUAL SHOT.
MAYBE TWO SHOTS HERE.
BUT THAT WOULD BE IT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, NOVAVAX HAS A
VACCINE OUT.
WE'LL TALK TO THAT COMPANY'S
CEO.
IT'S THE FOURTH VACCINE TO DEAL
WITH THIS.
IT WILL BE SOMETHING PROMISING
FOR THE 20% OR SO OF THE
POPULATION THAT IS NOT
VACCINATED.
SOME ARE LOOKING AT THAT AND
SAYING, WE GO THROUGH THIS AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
THIS IS WORSE THAN THE FLU
THING.
THIS IS MULTIPLE SHOTS.
MULTIPLE BOOSTERS.
MULTIPLE PAIN IN THE NECKS.
WHAT DO YOU TELL THEM?
>> I'M NOT SAYING WE'RE GOING TO
BE THERE.
BUT REMEMBER, WE NEED FLU SHOTS
EVERY YEAR BECAUSE FLU IS
VARIABLE AND WE STILL LOSE 20,
30, 60,000 AMERICAN FROM FLU
EVERY YEAR.
>> Neil: ADMIRAL, THIS IS MORE
THAN THE FLU.
IT WOULDN'T BE JUST ONE SHOT.
SOME GUYS ARE SAYING EVERY THREE
MONTHS, SIX MONTHS.
ARE THERE ANY RULES ON THIS?
>> WELL, LOOK, THE DATA DON'T
SHOW AND I DON'T THINK WE'LL BE
THERE THAT WE'LL NEED DOSES
EVERY THREE, SIX NINE MONTHS.
I'M HOPEFUL WITH AN OMICRON
SPECIFIC VACCINE, EVEN THOUGH
WE'VE HAD VARIANTS, THIS IS
STILL THE MAIN OMICRON STRAIN.
HOPEFULLY IT WILL PROVIDE US A
BETTER DIRECTION.
NOVAVAX IS A GREAT NEW WEAPON IN
THE GAME THAT WILL SOON BE
AVAILABLE.
IT'S A DIFFERENT TYPE OF VACCINE
AND WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW THAT
COVERAGE WEARS OUT OR NOT OR IS
MORE DURABLE.
>> Neil: NOW THEY'RE LOOKING TO
EXACTLY WHO MET THE PRESIDENT,
WHEN, HOW CLOSE THEY GOT,
WHETHER THEY SHOOK HANDS.
HE'S BEEN ALL HOVER THE WORLD,
MET WITH LEADERS IN SAUDI
ARABIA, ISRAEL, THE PALESTINIAN
AUTHORITY TO SAY NOTHING OF
CAMPAIGN STOPS INCLUDING ONE
JUST YESTERDAY.
WHO IS MOST VULNERABLE IN THAT
GROUP AND DOES IT GO BACK A WEEK
AGO BEFORE HE WAS OFFICIALLY,
YOU KNOW, DIAGNOSED WITH THIS
TODAY.
>> SO WHEN DON'T KNOW WHEN TIME
ZERO WAS.
HE WAS DIAGNOSED ON AN ANTIGEN
TEST.
PARTICULARLY WITH THE OMICRON
VARIANTS, BA-4 AND BA-5, HE
COULD HAVE BEEN POSITIVE AND
INFECTIOUS FOR SEVERAL DAYS
BEFORE HE BECAME POSITIVE ON
THAT TEST.
SO GOING BACK A WEEK IS A LONG
TIME.
CERTAINLY IN THE TWO OR THREE
DAYS BEFORE HE BECAME POSITIVE
BY AN ANTIGEN TEST, HE COULD
HAVE BEEN TRANSMITTING THE VIRUS
TO OTHER PEOPLE.
SO EVERYONE WHO HAD BEEN CLOSE
TO HIM ARE AT RISK.
I THINK WE ALL HAVE TO ASSUME
WE'RE AT SOME DEGREE OF RISK AND
NEED TO HAVE OUR GUARD UP.
IT IS OUT THERE VERY PROMINENTLY
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WITH
THESE VARIANTS.
>> Neil: YEAH, YOU NEVER